Speaker 1: All right, I want to talk about
some Republican reactions to the recent Facebook
whistleblowers revelations, allegations, statements
during the testimony that happened earlier
this week.
That is going to give us a little bit of an
entry way into Matt Gates.
Then we'll talk about Matt Gates's recent
statements when actually questioned about
whether he's worried about the possible building
sex trafficking case against him.
It's all really, really wacky.
But let's start first with the Facebook stuff,
OK?
So Frances Hogan is the whistleblower.
We learned the identity of the whistleblower
Sunday night on 60 Minutes Monday, she testified
in Washington, D.C. Matt Gaetz is suggesting
that the whistleblower may be a false flag
being advised by former Obama staffers.
What it means to be a false flag whistleblower,
I don't know.
The documents have not been called inauthentic.
Facebook has just rejected some people's characterization
of the documents.
Facebook has denied that they do the things
the documents show that they do, but the documents
have not been called inauthentic authentic,
and so it just always starts to get conspiratorial
and weird.
Here's Matt Gaetz appearing on of course,
OANN, which we found out earlier today, is
90 percent funded by AT&T.
Let's start there.
Speaker 3: And that brings us to the non whistleblower
whistleblower.
I think folks should really question whether
or not this is a false flag.
Again, is apparently now being advised by
members of the Obama team.
Well, that certainly doesn't strike us as
someone trying to advance the conversation
to democratize access to information.
And when you get down to the core of what
she wants, it is a basis for Facebook to be
able to discriminate against viewpoints that
they don't particularly like.
Speaker 1: So this is a couple points here.
All right.
And then we're going to look at a clip also
of the brilliant Madison Cawthorn explaining
what he believes this is all about.
So a couple of different points here.
First of all.
The idea that all of this is to be able to
further suppress right wing viewpoints on
Facebook, right wing viewpoints dominate Facebook.
I mean, just just dominate Facebook.
You look at the top posts on Facebook.
Most days it's Ben Shapiro, it's Hannity,
it's Dan Bongino.
Occasionally there will be a Rachel Maddow
clip.
It's Tucker.
It's it's actually quite the opposite in practice
of what's going on on Facebook.
Reports that Mark Zuckerberg has been meeting
with Tucker Carlson and other right wing media
figures doesn't mean that he believes in their
political views, necessarily.
But the idea that Facebook is just very disrespectful
to right wing viewpoints overwhelmingly right
wing nut free is spreading on Facebook.
It's a nexus of this stuff.
So that's Matt Gates.
Then we go to Madison Cawthorn, who in his
sort of mealy mouthed way, says kind of the
same thing.
This is all a way to try to justify censorship
of right wingers,
Speaker 3: but I don't think that he should
be forced out.
But you know, I have to tell you, and this
is purely conjecture.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Glad you mentioned that, Madison.
Good, good.
So below where
Speaker 3: they had come up to Capitol Hill,
who went out on to 60 Minutes just on Sunday
and then in 48 hours, she wound up in front
of Congress.
Let me tell you, that's the fastest I've ever
seen Congress move.
Speaker 1: Now let's deal with that, first
of all.
60 Minutes films their stuff well in advance.
It's an edited, produced show, and there is
no question that people knew this was happened.
This was airing on Sunday night with all of
the different legal clearances that have to
take place and so many different things.
I don't know when it was filmed the interview
with the whistleblower Francis Hogan, but
the idea that you know of whoever, right?
I mean, Chuck Schumer sitting at home and
Sunday night, the interview shows up on TV
and he calls and he says, Ma'am, come to Washington.
Of course, that's not the way it happened.
So.
So just the timing thing as part of the basis
for this conspiracy really is what it is.
Conspiracy theory just doesn't pass the sniff
test.
Speaker 3: I believe that she is actually
there to try and advocate for more censorship
and less freedom of speech because this is
an anti-competition marketplace for the Facebook
as long as more regulations.
Speaker 1: She didn't argue for that.
She simply didn't argue for that.
And so this is sort of the story that they
are latching onto.
And it's really, really interesting because
there's this incredible it's not even a hypocrisy,
but you have this idea of they don't want
regulation, but they want Facebook and some
of these social media platforms to be forced
to allow the right wing stuff to be published,
which is regulation.
But then when Congress actually acts and people
start asking questions and holding hearings
to say, Well, maybe there should be regulation,
they say No, no, no, that regulates that type
of regulation, censorship, which so did you
want because it's still regulation to go to
Facebook and say, you've got to publish everything
Ben Shapiro says and everything Madison Cawthorn
says, or whatever the case may be, that's
very heavy handed government intrusion into
a private company's business model.
Publicly traded, but it's not a government
entity is the point.
So that's very heavy handed regulation, which
they want.
But then at the same time, Frances Hogan is
brought to D.C. and let's figure out what
we can do.
And now the fear is, Oh no, no, no, no.
Democrats are going to try to regulate Facebook
and to try to live.
It's not about principles is the point endlessly.
I've told you these people, they claim to
be about principles.
They're not.
They're about whatever justifies the outcome
they want at the time.
They'll tell you a is the reason that the
outcome should be the outcome.
And the next day, they'll tell you the opposite
of.
As long as it points to the outcome they want,
that's all they care about.
So that's Matt Gates and Madison Cawthorn
on Facebook.
Let's stick with Matt Gates now in our next
story and give you an update there.